oh no way did you catch that I didn't
catch that did I miss that what is going
on there citizens of the reject Nation
we are about to watch from heavy
spoilers The Last of Us episode 1 Easter
eggs and breakdown join with me of
course the man who's covering The Last
of Us series with me Andrew Gordon
Twitter Instagram
agor711 who's got a firefly shirt today
yes I do shout out to the guy uh at
Trader Joe's before I came here
recognized the shirt said to me dude is
that a last of a shirt and then the
cashier's like oh my God that's awesome
so apparently people want to be
fireflies I know that's the side you
want to be on people team happy all the
way how many viewers do we lose by
saying that Paul one of my best mates he
actually encouraged the reaction to this
and I was like well yeah I was already
gonna watch it so might as well react to
it on camera let's see what details us
Gamers missed over here you excited
Andrew I'm super excited anything last
of us leave a like people let's see
what's going on
okay so the Last of Us episode one is
now out and I'm so excited to talk about
it the first game is my favorite of all
time and I've bought the PS3 version the
PS4 remaster and even the PS5 remake
that released a couple of months ago
this is a game I've completed numerous
times on grounded mode and the series is
something I've been desperate to do a
deep dive on if you haven't played it
then don't worry because we won't be
spoiling what happens down the line as I
want you to enjoy the twists and turns
as much as I did on my first playthrough
however I may need to touch upon certain
things due to characters that get name
dropped yet but I'll only bring them up
in our super spoiler section at the end
of the video which I'll give you a heads
up on it I can't wait I'm nice like that
I don't like the game the series starts
off in 1968. originally we watched as
Sarah woke up in her bed and ventured
about the house but here they do it
differently rather than throwing us in
at the night of the outbreak we get some
backstory that wasn't even filled in in
the source material the game told us
very little about the virus Beyond being
caused by cordyceps which had mutated to
infect humans these real-life fungi
exist in the jungle and the parasite
infects insects and also anthropods
beginning in 1968 though we see a TV
show in which two scientists do a big
deal time about what the biggest threat
to humanity is the first one goes up
about how we may have a pandemic level
event that's caused by a strain of
influenza which awkward now both games
were made before the pandemic and the
creative team have retroactively added
this into the show to comment on it in
my opinion I think that's a great
addition to have it be included like the
touch on global warming they include the
whole thing about a pandemic it makes
even the game in retrospect feel that
much more relevant and a little bit more
Timeless in a way the reason I liked it
too is it just it fills in some gaps
even though like they go into a little
explanation there's some newspaper
clippings in the video game that explain
a little bit about the quarter steps and
how it affects the brain but like
actually getting this full-on
explanation from John Hannah I say that
right I love the explanation it was
really well delivered monologue too but
just again it fills in that Gap that now
when you play the video game you have
more of a backstory of how the quarter
steps work and how it can affect ants
and that when it does hit the human body
how it takes time like yeah you know you
run from stage to Stage so I thought
that was a really nice addition designed
his mentions how airplanes are a new
element that will help viruses like this
spread easier and later on we see
several planes flying overhead as Sarah
Joel and Tommy make their escape they
add a lot of focus to them during the
truck scene and actually change up how
the crash happens originally it was
caused by another one hitting them but
they do a fake episode yeah
I love that now the sign is played by
John Hannah talks about the threat of
cordyceps and how climate change could
allow the fungi to spread from the more
tropical regions of the world to human
population centers he talks about how
cordyceps work and this is some yet the
scientists have studied in the wild the
fungi infect their host and they then
fill them with hallucinations that cause
them to act a certain way a lot of the
time they'll get ants to climb high up
into the trees and then from here
they'll kill the host and get them to
spread their spores one thing I thought
that was so creepy about the game is
that we'd often stumble across the
infected whilst they were unaware we
were in the area you'd often catch them
subbing away in corners and the creative
team said it was horrendous being one of
them due to the parasite basically
infecting your brain similar to how the
Spore ants were set up in fact it would
lay down somewhere and die and they'd
become points of infection that could
fire spores out into the air we see one
of these later on in the episode but
they do stay their hand and don't reveal
the later stages of the infected in this
first entry the character also says this
very important line snow cures they
don't exist it's not even possible to
make them that's why Ali becomes so
important later on because she seems
like the last how to dig Humanity out of
this hellhole they end this speech by
clearly setting up the stakes and
showing why the world ends up the way it
does we lose that's another thing I love
about the game and whereas we normally
watch the outbreak and go from there we
get a massive time gem to see Humanity
far far in the future I actually didn't
realize that they're saying that there's
no cure in the beginning that's a
perfect way to bookend the episode with
revealing that perhaps Ellie might be
the Cure better structuring because
again in the video game we only see
Ellie when they meet Marlene and then
she takes them over to Ellie and then we
find out when she's infected like oh my
God it doesn't kind of click that she
could be the cure for mankind until a
little bit later when they I mean they
do find out that she's infected and then
she shows them the mark but again we
don't really get to that reveal that you
know what they're exactly taking her
over there for it it just it happens a
little later on yeah no I agree with you
that was a night definitely a nice
bookend and I really enjoyed that
monologue we got from John Hannah just
again it set the stakes and just made
you understand like of Ellie's
importance after this we cut to the
title sequence which is presented in a
similar way to the black and white one
that started up the game there's lots of
symbolism here with a fungus rising up
to create a Skyline showing how it's
become the dominant force in the world
who wants to see one creating a face
before Bonnie settling on the silhouette
sub Joe and Ellie the theme tune used
here is pulled directly from the game
and it instantly sets a tone of
solitarian Bleak storyline such a good
song
[Music]
so originally the game took place in
2013 which just so happened to be the
year of its release we then got the 28
time Jump like what we have in the show
which took us to the air 2033 the game
was littered with calendars mocking the
date and in the second one you could
even find a PlayStation 3 with a copy I
would always find PS3 the series changes
things up 2003 we have the main parts
take place in 2023 we start off in 2003
and much like how the game opens we see
things from Sarah's perspective now
originally that had the player waking up
on the night of the outbreak which also
happened to be Joel's birthday yeah
though we get a full day in the life of
Sarah and the entire time I was wishing
I could sit and watch this with someone
who had no idea about the games and be
like does he know Sarah is very much a
reflection of Ali they've even given her
a backpack which wasn't in the game to
make her more closely married to her she
also wears a hurricane drops t-shirt
which Sarah two wore in the game yeah
that had the 2 2012 Tour whereas this is
the O2 once it doesn't mess too much
with the timeline neat little Easter egg
on it is that all the locations are so
that are in the order of places that the
characters visit in the game oh that's
so cool we pick up the scene by starting
at Sarah's window and this is important
iconography as an open window is also
Summit that's used on the game's menu
screen it also ties into something that
we'll talk about in the super spoiler
section and this window shot could
become something defining down the line
on Sarah's room we see a band poster for
The Clash and also Destiny's Child this
is similar to her room in the game in
which he had a halcon's drop poster and
also one for the in-universe movie
called dawn of the wolf Destiny's Child
poster says Survivor and it's not this
child's Destiny to be a Survivor oh no
too soon too soon now interestingly the
calendar says August but we do get a
confirm later on that the outbreak
happened on September 26th because
that's also Joel's birthday she's just
forgot to change it and that's kind of
some stuff like this to show she's just
a Carefree kid that's just so sad when
you think about it from Joel's
perspective it's not only the day he
lost his daughter it's also the day of
the outbreak so every time there's the
anniversary of the outbreak this is his
birthday
that's so horrible it's a terrible day
to have your birthday it's like people's
birthday is like being on 9 11 or
something that it would suck to have a
birthday on that day going into the the
difference that you know starting the
video game The Night of the outbreak
from Sarah's perspective to spending the
whole day with Sarah getting to see the
town like literally like okay we're
getting little hints so that something's
happening you know we see the the market
that's closing early or the where she
goes to get the watch fixed for her dad
we see there are little hints of what's
to come so I love how they again I liked
it a little bit more here just getting
to spend one more normal day before
whatever what ends up happening just
seeing it from Sarah's perspective just
because we we have such a limited time
it gets you more emotionally invested in
the characters even though it was very
sad what happens in the video game like
it seemed more sad here because we get
to spend a little more time with her
yeah well you got to do a little bit
more in the show because you are not
being Sarah with holding a controller or
you're watching Sarah so that's why you
have to do a little bit more add-on I
think it's great yeah she was really
good too now they also picked to set it
around summer because the heat would
help the spread of the cordyceps and it
adds the idea of the seasonal storyline
that the last of us has Joe says he's 36
making him 56 when we join him later and
over his left shoulder we can see a
football on the rack will not say soccer
ball your Chumps and this is actually an
important bit of iconography in the game
Sarah plays soccer celebrating her
winning a trophy and the character goes
back and forth over whether to
acknowledge this or not we get a great
catch down seeing when we go to the news
report on the radio we can see a photo
of them all together to the right of it
great catch you see Sarah moving about
the house you also get a good look at
the football again alongside an acoustic
guitar on the other side of the room
Charles the king guitar player and we
learn in the game that he even wanted to
become a singer at some point in his
early life however he and his wife at
Sarah when they were very young and she
ended up leaving him which is when it
took on the responsibility of raising
her at this point walks in Tommy played
by Gabriel Luna he sounds exactly like
Tommy doesn't he does I actually closed
my eyes and couldn't tell the difference
definitely the same if I was having
pancakes
they got no clue
but we ain't the only town it's crazy
it's crazy due to a job he has to work a
double shift to get stuff finished for
the day at this point of news report
goes out over the radio and we hear a
mention of Jakarta we don't know where
the outbreak originated from due to the
game not really telling us but it is
possible that this is the show filling
in the backstory of how it came about
it's of course a very hot country and
this would tie back to the climate
comments made by the scientists earlier
on Joe's t-shirts inside out and I like
how they have him done in the gray one
that he had at the start of the game
this is reflected in Tommy 2 who's
wearing a summon I want to say summon
some ensured like how he does in the
intro now Sarah then goes to Joel's room
and takes his watch out the drawers so
that she can get it fixed in the game
she just bought him but here she's using
his money to get it fixed up because
she's a cheapskate she's a bloody
Cheapskate a Joe's watch is extremely
important as it breaks on the night the
infected rise up but he keeps it with
him as a Memento though he shuts himself
off from talking about Sarah there are
points where it can be seen longingly
staring at it as a reminder of what is
Left Behind she also finds a knife in
his drawer hitting at him potentially
having a darker past and outside we see
that the truck has combat veteran on it
and from this it's possible that he
might have been part of Operation Desert
Storm however this could actually belong
to Tommy as well as he's the one driving
it Captain Obvious here but bit of food
stuck it in quickly a Tommy did end up
joining the fireflies when it all went
down and his experience in the Army
could have been the reason why he got so
high up in the ranks Joel says to
Marlene later that she turned his own
brother against him and we might see
more of the group from Tommy's
perspective anyway that's enough that
would be really cool if we got an
episode that is all from because they're
in the game you don't you catch up with
Tommy eventually you and you learn like
what he's been up to essentially but we
don't get to see any of the journey that
led to him and Joel dividing during this
time of the Apocalypse 20 years later
absolutely there's only some dialogue
again not going to go into spoilers here
but there's only some dialogue mentioned
about what happened between Joel and
Tommy so uh yeah I agree with you just
seeing an episode that maybe focuses on
Tommy's perspective what led to their I
guess you would call Fallout where he
ends up trying not to spoil it where he
ends up going to
um just seeing like what leads to that I
think that would definitely be
interesting and again it's a different
thing that could be satisfying adds more
to the mystery that we didn't get
answered in the video game now when you
play the video game go oh okay now
that's answered for me and the
difference with this one too is that it
feels like almost Canon to the game
because of the fact that Neil druckman
is so heavily involved in it too you
know yeah as opposed to just being an
adaptation it feels like an expansion
now we also meet the Neighbors at this
point and in the game this is where the
first infected attack from however it
wasn't an old lady and instead it was a
man that attacked them called Jimmy
Cooper what's going on it's Coopers
something right with them
I think there's
six
oh my God a picture of George W bush who
would have been president at this time
due to him being in the job from 2001 to
2009. yeah we can see the infection has
started to hit Humanity as we can catch
a student twitching away which we later
see at the federal Camp is one of the
signs of infection the cordyceps
attached to someone's brain and hours
which is why these little mannerisms
start before it takes control I love the
little detail as Sarah steps off the bus
and we can catch an advert for a Nokia
3310 which I think I probably had snake
in 2003. snake 2 reigning Champion [ __ ]
you don't at me I love it anyway Sarah
gets the watch fixed and we start to see
that summing might be off due to the
amount of sirens and the fact the shop
owners close up have you seen the quiet
place too I have not well what's
interesting is a quiet place was often
compared to sort of the tone and Vibe
like the whole atmosphere was sort of
compared to the last of us a quiet place
part two has an opening that shows you
the day of the outbreak this felt like
oh almost kind of watching a quiet place
part two but a quiet place part two was
first called told that that was sort of
taking inspiration for the last of us as
good as a cool like cyclical thing I
don't know I just thought about it if
you guys seen quiet place too you know
what I'm talking about they're likely
making a run for it like we see people
doing later on and I I appreciate the
blind thing was a little clock face
Sarah visits her neighbors the adlers
and she asks to borrow the DVDs
curtising by Patu Yep this is the film
not later popped up and The Last of Us
Part Two during a conversation has some
big spoilers that kind of Riff on this
that I'll say for the super spoiler
section and I'll also go through what
was said in regards to the plot of the
movie now Sarah later gives this to Joel
and the reviews say it's one of the best
performances I've ever seen little
little bit of a Funny Story here that
always makes me chuckle but Jonathan and
Paul Ross both used to be massive movie
critics and they had a bet with each
other about who could get on the back of
the box for Batman Forever they both
wrote really stupid reviews and that's
why the back of the VHS tape for it has
the quote from Jonathan Ross saying one
of the greatest movies ever
and the dog is acting strange too the
dogs were used by the bandits to show
whether someone had cordyceps or not as
they of course didn't have the fancy tag
that the federal agents do now at this
point we get Jill and Sarah having a
conversation on the sofa which is pulled
directly from the game I think this is
it's nice but I
I think it's stuck it's not what no no
it's not sitting on different sides
what a change I don't hear anything
did you get the money for this where'd
you get the money for this drugs I sell
hardcore drugs oh drugs I saw hardcore
drugs that's better when I do I love how
they do some of the stuff about him and
the father and daughter moment is the
last real conversation they have cut to
Sarah asleep and this plays out similar
how it does in the game only this time
they make the pair a bit closer by
having her dude on his lap in the game I
don't think we found out why Joe left
but we did see texts on his phone asking
where the hell is PS5 if you want to see
the phone call was learning that one of
the infected started attacking people at
the bar and Tommy got locked up for
fighting them she'll ask to bail him out
and he put Sarah to bed which is when we
see her waking up which is how the game
properly starts
as you see news reports that are
documenting some of the attacks they
have an explosion happen which then
appears on the news as well whereas here
she's woken up by the Sands of passing
Choppers and Ducks the little Pooch
Murphy jumps up at the patio which I
think is playing on the dog we hear
barking that we then hear yelping as
Sarah gets to the door
what's up
oh yes yes oh yeah I remember oh Sarah
visits the atlas and here she finds that
the elderly woman is now up about and
eating people I got a lot of flashes
here to the first zombie that you come
across in Resident Evil with the hair
loss making this appear really similar
who've actually added some into the
affected yeah and we can see that the
cordyceps comes out of her mouth which
wasn't present in the game those were
recorded sets I thought that was hair
that's what I thought too I thought she
was eating hair the whole time oh that's
just that's even worse
oh my God whoa that was a good science
lesson we just got oh man that is so
gross in nature they try and get as high
as possible so they can spread the
spores easier and I'll love this
addition to the infected that makes them
more horrifying Shaolin Tommy arrive
with shells swinging a wrench similar to
how you use melee weapons in the game
they jump in the truck and you'll love
how we can see the atlas in the street
now showing how quick the infection
spreads the truck ride is really similar
to it with a being word for word at
points okay yeah in one way in the
hospital which is the other and this is
all ripped right out of the sauce
materials they head towards the hospital
and this is of course where most of the
outbreak would be at its worst due to
people being taken there after they got
sick we learned that the adults actually
went there to get medicine for the
elderly one and this is likely how she
picked up the infection in the first
place anyway enough of me talking let's
play the scene side by side so you can
see how close they are
some sort of parasite or something
there's some kind of parasite are we
sick
no of course not are we sick no of
course not no cell phone no radio yeah
we're doing great a minute ago newsman
wouldn't shut up cell phone no radio and
things man wouldn't shut up
that's Lewis's Farm
I hope that some [ __ ] made it flip that
too it's on the right side
it's Jimmy's Place
[Music]
who do you think you're doing keep
driving I got a Kid Joe so do we we have
room hey
someone else will come along
[ __ ] everybody had the same [ __ ] idea
everyone and their mother had the same
damn idea
it's crazy
the attention to detail no no no come on
people move what are they running from
get us out of here let me try it this is
a great edit man
after the truck's thrown off the road
Sarah's unable to walk and Joel has to
carry hair this is where we take control
of him in the game and it leads to them
running through a restaurant chased by
the infected like what we see here at
this point we'll get what's probably the
most devastating part in the whole story
normally in post-apocalyptic Tales When
characters run into soldiers it's often
a sign of safety they're used as a way
to show their people of someone looking
after them but here it's the complete
opposite order to shoot Joel and Sarah
he fires upon them and this ends up
killing Sarah now watch this scene a ton
of times in the game and it was only
upon this watch too that I realized that
they did this because Cyril was injured
and they might have suspected a bite
anyway
I'm going to show you how it works
alongside the game
that was different going the Tommy had
too
[Music]
move your hands big this is a fantastic
breakdown oh my God
I know baby don't know
this one you're gonna be okay baby stay
with me
no I know I know I know I know it hurts
[Music]
baby baby listen to me I gotta get you
up
come on baby please I know baby I know
Sarah
come on baby girl come on baby girl I
gotta get you
baby
don't do this to me babe don't do this
to me
um
[Laughter]
completely gut-wrenching and it's the
defining mom and Joel's life that
changes him for the worse again the
actors those scenes in the game are so
memorable gotta give credit to actors
when it doesn't feel like they're just
doing impersonations or just doing you
know some type of recreation like
they're making it their own truly
secondly this is not even a nitpick or a
criticism whatsoever there's just one
little detail that's always stood out to
me about what the game did in that
moment that I've preferred that versus
what the show did again not a criticism
totally love how to handle in the show
when they do see Sarah who's dying and
then the camera doesn't cut it pans over
to Tommy and Tommy's like Joel and then
it pans back and you see she's dead
would I have liked that to be in the
show sure that to not have it cut back
yeah I don't know that's just something
I want to point out that I slightly
prefer just if if it was in one take
like that it hits you a little bit
harder yeah I can totally feel it like
it Harps more in the moment they're both
handled very very well done but I
thought he made a great point I mean
I've played the video game and I
apologize to anyone who thinks I'm I'm
really stupid for not just thinking
about this in the moment the 50 million
times I played the video get the first
game that the soldier uh the reason he
got the order to kill Sarah or to shoot
them was because Sarah was injured and
he mistook that for her being you know
possibly infected and I really never put
that together I just figured hey they
don't know who's infected so they're
just they're gonna just kill anyone in
that area that's not what I just figured
but that makes even more sense it's a
great attention to detail the scene is
the key to understanding the character
and it sets up basically everything
that's to come from here we get a time
Jump of 20 years and a big section that
wasn't in the game here we watch a child
out in the wilderness making their way
to the federal Camp which is located in
Boston the red shirt reminded me a lot
of the girl in Schindler's List that we
see moving through the devil great catch
aside similar to what we see y'all doing
his role is also very similar to some
characters in the stand with there being
Body Disposal Crews that had to get rid
of the dead after the world had
destabilized this child's found to be
infected and the federal soldiers end up
euthanizing them bedra is basically the
remnants of the federal government but
they were seen as fascists in The Last
of Us Universe they had strict rules
that sends people to death for very very
little and in the game were first
introduced to them forcing people to
their knees and shooting the infected
now because of their strict rule many
resistance groups rose up including the
fireflies several Rebels rose up and
they propped up their own leaders which
if they were better or not is another
question entirely now I think here
they're painted down a better light and
though they kill the kid they do it
mercifully and even lie to make it seem
like they're gonna be taking care of
them now what's very Bleak about the
last of us is that there's barely any
kids in the entire thing most of the
people we follow are middle aged and as
they say children are our future the
fact there's so few kids shows how
doomed human he is and Ali represents
not only the hope and the Cure but also
in the fact that children can make it in
this world that was one of my favorite
details too Tess is talking with you all
later on and says that one of the kids
that beat me up they were born after the
outbreak like a big part of his their
social behavior they might not be as
well equipped in a lot of ways you know
yeah because we're born outbreak yeah
yeah no it makes total sense and we also
see a poster that breaks down the full
time to infection and we can see that
Ellie's bite would be roughly two to
eight hours with one being on the foot
giving someone a day one's in the neck
and face give someone 5 to 15 minutes
which explains why the atlas got up so
quickly in the truck scene interesting
kids killed after the scanner flashes
red on them and this very much
foreshadows the Fate that would have
come to Ali had gel not saved her life
yeah it's heartbreaking because we don't
really know what the Red symbol means
and part of me was hoping that the kid
made it out after the God said you're
safe sadly though we see her body in the
back of a truck and this is how I
reintroduced to Joel and where he is now
carries the body almost like how he did
with Sarah and dumps him on the fire
showing no attachment at all at this
point we see Russian cards being handed
out he's also appeared in the game and
they look identical to how they did in
that we then good shots of the city and
also get a curfew sign this pops up in
the game as well and it's identical to
the one you see when you first walk
around Boston we see some of the
citizens and catch a guy in an Al Gore
Lieberman campaign chair from the 2000s
election campaign don't know why he's
wearing this but they could possibly be
reminiscing about a world in which Gore
was in charge because because of all of
his climate change stuff or they might
be the only clothes they've been able to
get a hold of in the last 20 years they
probably haven't been reproducing new
clothes because they could cause dissent
and we see how people are hanged for
leaving the QC this is something that
Joel does regularly and he works as a
Smuggler we catch a federal Soldier
twitching but it's not because it's
infected and you'll in fact ends up
selling him pills in the game this is
something that Tess is coming back from
when we first meet air so I'll take one
guess the uh whole deal went South and
the client made up with our pills is
that about right the guard shows up
later on when he catches them outside
and I love this addition to the series
for when he pops back up we pretty much
don't spend any time with the guards
Beyond chucking them out in the game and
it shows how they're all working in
Shades of Gray with them wanting people
to exit the qz whilst also killing those
that do he then brings up the Firefly
Attacks and these end up bringing tests
from her captives you see a big bit of
graffiti for the fireflies on the wall
and this is similar to the radio
messages that Marlene was putting out in
the game remember when you're lost in
the darkness look for the light now from
here we jump to test in a moment that we
weren't really privy to in the game
Abby's dead in that we start with y'all
waking up and she shows up to the
apartment beaten up after two people
were sent after her by Robert it turned
out that Jill and Tess had sold him some
guns that the fireflies also got here
though it all centers around the truck
battery I actually prefer it with a
battery being something they can use to
get a car to get out of there and it
kind of ties back to the the backstory
with Tommy Now They do change things up
from the game and the first part in the
future follows Joel and Tess as they
hunt Robert down eventually they catch
and kill him which is when Moline
arrives and it's this that leads into
the early mission interestingly
Marlene's played by mil Dandridge who
just so also happened to play her in the
game actually think that like them
cutting it out made sense story wise too
because I feel like they're more
selective with the violence here in the
show just I'm getting that just from the
first episode that they're more
selective with their violence in the
game it's almost as if they set up that
mission so you as a player can get
acquainted with how to shoot how to kill
how to melee and do all that stuff
before getting into like the real
missions yeah so it seemed like it was
necessary for the gameplay but for the
show itself I guess we don't actually
need this Robert mission that they
completely excised out yeah in terms of
servicing the story for the TV show and
then setting up the whole Tommy bit and
like you know for the car battery and
all that no this makes a lot more sense
and there might be things like in The
Nine episodes we watch there might be
things like I wish they didn't you cut
that out or maybe I don't know I haven't
obviously I have not watched all nine
episodes but I will say that the choices
that they made in episode one thus far I
was like okay I didn't mind that they
cut that out okay this was a nice
addition okay that was the right show I
I just thought it was flawlessly done
the first episode now here we pick up
with test tied up and Robert begging her
to let things go it shows how much of a
g she is and in the game she killed the
cactus herself the Firefly explosion
allows her to escape and this is riffing
on the scene in the game when they got
across a checkpoint and one blows off
which makes Tess and Joe flee through
the tunnels now from here we jump to
Ellie chained up she's currently being
observed due to being bit and we see her
standing in front of a window again
calling back to that iconography naughty
dog have added in their own and shot at
Easter egg and Ellie's wearing the same
[ __ ] that Young Nathan Drake had on oh
no way did you catch that already catch
that I never played those games oh
batteries full he returned to the
apartment why did I miss that hearing
Echoes of his brother screaming Joel
Tommy and Tess had to do horrendous
things in order to survive and we might
even get the backstory filled in beyond
what we got in the game kurtigil waking
up which is where we pick up after the
time Jump and we see Tess telling him
about Robert in a scene that Echoes how
we first meet it they man up and decide
to head out which is when we cut to
Marlene leader of fireflies we then see
them planning attacks with a map on the
table a forces is starting to ask
questions about why people are dying and
why there's a random girl locked up just
down the hall Marlene is wearing clothes
similar to the game and they're planning
to move every Firefly out of the city
because of Ellie's immunity we even see
one trying to recruit Joel and I love
how the fireflies are slotted in almost
every aspect of the city also worth
buying out the test is wearing the exact
same clothes that she hasn't in the game
except for the bandana which uh I like
that button now when Joel stands against
his sleeves too you can also see several
posters including one in the bottom left
for Curtis Viper 2. at this point
Marlene goes to Ali and she throws her
bag over this is exactly the same as the
game and it even has the little Cyclops
head like what the character has in that
you also see her pull out a Fleck knife
which is something that she uses
throughout the original work Molly gives
her the keys to her handcuffs and she
brings up the Federal military school
future spoilers that will not spoil now
but we will talk about them later on in
the video and how this ties in a part of
the story coming up now it's sort of
touched upon here but Marlene had Ellie
drafted into a fedra program as a child
and this was to keep it safe she knew
her mother and wanted her away from the
fireflies and also brings up Riley which
we'll save that for later on anyway she
warns Ellie that she'll be killed that
people know about her and this comes to
be true Jill and Tess make their way
through some buildings and they move in
the ground which is a similar thing to
what they did in the game now they come
across an infected person who's grown
into the wall and I absolutely love the
look of this oh as it is so good the
more mutated ones that appear later on
everything that created immersion
experience green wool which looks like
it's ripped right out of the PlayStation
classic when moving through the tunnels
you encounter someone stuck to your wall
and I was kind of hopping they pull out
the gas masks for this bit but
unfortunately they don't and those stuck
into the wall would attach and then fire
spores in the environment but sadly they
cut that out here anyway it leads them
to the Firefly base which is where they
find Robert dead in the game it was Tess
who shot him but either way he gets
capped in the same place at this point
they come across a wounded Marlene
similar The Source material and Ellie
attempts to attack Joel which is how
she's first introduced in the original
work Jolin tessitas with transporting
Ellie to a bunch of fireflies and in
exchange they'll be given a whole truck
they agree now we get a scene in which
they rest up in a room whilst the rain
Pours Down this is similar to how it
played out in the original with him all
laying low here for the first time and
Joel getting some should I Ellie finds
code words and throughout the game you'd
often come across notes with crude
scribblings in them detailing things
like safe codes backstories and
information about the groups you didn't
counter this is inside a billboard book
and it details how songs from each
decade detail whether there's a new
stock in are the 80s have a big X next
to them and we learn that this means
danger this is very important as come
the end of the episode we hear a song
detailing the danger that they're
heading into oh my God she's open on the
1970s and at the top you can catch the
Long and Winding Road slash For You Blue
released by The Beatles this single had
for you blue is the B side to it and the
long and Winding Road could be a little
nod to the big journey ahead of them big
reach oh that's not rich
we'll talk about more in the spoiler
section I've been teasing agile falls
asleep and we get some repeated lines
from the game
you mumble in your sleep
now that night they sneak through the
streets and I remember playing this and
it being so intense as the trucks moved
past and spotlights rained down outside
the wall you sneak underground and then
pop up like what we see here and have to
avoid search lights as they pierce the
surroundings love the juxtaposition of a
big sign that says welcome which is of
course something that the Shadows of the
federal soldiers completely go against
we then get this line from Ellie
actually outside
holy [ __ ] I'm actually outside
the ones that you ended up crawling
through at this point they come across
the soldier in the original they were
caught by two in the game Ali attacked
them upon being scanned and Joel and
Tess jumped and shot them respectively
here though he gets a PTSD flashback of
Sarah's death which triggers him into
attacking I actually think this works
better especially with a soldier
returning and it shows that Joel's even
willing to attack people they know if it
rubs him the wrong way well you see
that's what I mean by the additions and
changes be specifically that like those
are just guards in the game but here
when they when I say like they're making
the violence count more that's what
they're doing they're making the deaths
really count versus you know just
killing off some random people kind of
service Joel as a character yeah for
sure and in the game I would say just
again Joel's a character where he keeps
things bottled in so to actually see
like the PTSD and the trauma of what
happened with Sarah like being let out
and then also having Ellie actually see
the side of Joel this early on in the
relationship I thought again very
interesting choice like you said it's IT
services Joel's a character gives him
some interesting development to me comes
off as someone who's willing to do
whatever it takes to protect and also
just the PTSD side of it just what he's
dealing with 20 years of living with his
daughter's death uh just again I loved
it the discovery is biting she says look
look this is three weeks old nobody lost
more than a day it's three weeks old no
everyone turns I actually like that
delivery in the game though [ __ ]
it's three weeks the alarm rings and the
group head through the fence which is
when we cut to the radio to hear the
song never let me down again by Depeche
Mode it contains lyrics like I'm taking
a ride with my best friend sort of
playing into the show now this signals
the incoming danger as we watch the
group head to the twins
on the top of this we hear the Cry of
and infected and we end the episode with
a lingering shot on them now we've hit
that long-awaited super spoiler section
and from this point on we'll be covering
things from both games so if you haven't
played them then thanks for sticking
with me I'll see you next week you
better be back mate you you promised you
would anyway yeah spoilers just just
wait for everyone to leave right okay
they're gone now the first point is
Joel's guitar that we see in the
beginning of the episode this is how the
second game opens with him strumming
away on it Turtles had the second game
ends with Ellie playing on it too but
she's enabled
due to Hell losing her fingers we also
get a lingering shot of the window to
close the game out which is very
reminiscent of how the scene with Sarah
opens him with the menu now in the
episode there's of course the mention of
Riley as well didn't want to spoil it
for those that didn't know but you're
here now so you either play the game or
you don't care and this was the girl
that was with Ellie on the night that
she got bit this is all chronicled in
the Left Behind DLC which is basically
to them all before she shipped off with
the fireflies the parent of kissing and
Riley agrees to stay but the piece is
interrupted by the infected who end up
swarming the area Riley dies and Ellie
of course survives which he carries a
lot of guilt over now early on in the
episode the sinus talks about how the
fungus devours its host from the inside
and where we look at the clickers we can
see the entire top part of their head
has been replaced by the fungi the
scientist also explains how she's a
fungi being something we use for
penicillin but it can maintain a host
for a prolonged period of time in the
game we've caused meet the infected
decades down the line and we can see
just how far they mutated
which is where I'm guessing they'll head
to after they meet Henry and Sam this
was the location they camped out at and
it's probably going to be somewhere that
appears later on the series along with
all the Riley stuff not really an Easter
egg but Sarah's played by Nico Parker
who's also the daughter of danry Newton
or gas masks in the series Neil drockman
said it's because if there were Sports
in this world they would spread
everywhere and everyone would have to
wear masks all the time Fair Point that
kind of sucks as I love the aesthetic
they brought in the game and I I think
people could have suspended their
disbelief well probably not have even
had that cross their mind because we're
living in a world of zombie fungi wait
there's gonna be no spores no spores
what yeah oh what a disappointment
that's disappointing that's such a
signature motif of the game and it's
always so scary whenever you just
letting her like sportsmail like oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's about to go down and also too
I mean there are some reveals that
happen without masks so yeah I mean yeah
I agree with you that it is a little bit
disappointing I can understand their
perspective Sports would be everywhere
so everyone would always have to I can
understand that perspective too I mean
as long as the show's good I mean that's
one thing I'll be willing to forgive
possibly I gotta see the thing but I
agree with you it's definitely a little
bit sad that's the first piece of
information I've gotten about the show
that made me go oh what a day off
besides Sarah to me it would have given
the infected encounters to sort of
upside down from stranger things feel
but alas tis no more now that's what
Curtis invite but two this is the movie
that Joel and Sarah were gonna watch
together the night that she died he
never got to see it and in a bitter
Twist of irony it's also the movie that
giola Nelly were going to watch the
night that he died too Joel and Ali had
had a falling out due to her discovering
the truth but she had decided to see if
she could forgive him buying buying him
over to watch a movie that night they
were gonna watch it and here's what
Ellie had to say what movie you guys
gonna watch what's her
uh Curtis and Viper too that's the one
that's been on my that's great
oh wow
we used to watch these cheesy cheesy's
action movies
he's really into them oh no
I actually really like them too
what's Curtis and Viper 2 about
okay so two former Commandos that go
Rogue to fight bad guys and I think in
this one they go up against Russian
spies or something
I'm more interested in this than I
thought I would be all right so the
young one Viper he's a trained ninja and
he's a complete badass so how old is he
in the first movie
uh 10.
wait how many movies did they make of
this
uh I think they made four jeez you'll
actually saw the last one on the theater
am I crazy
yes
yes lastly is Bill and Frank the former
of which we know will be played by Nick
Offerman he's someone Jill and Tess have
had a long-standing relationship with
and upon reaching him Jill and Ellie are
escort to a school in order to get a car
battery they don't get it but they do
find Frank who discovered was bit and he
unalived himself which I have to say
because YouTube's been ridiculously
strict with the demonetization recently
oh yeah the pair will lovers but they
grew apart and Frank fled in order to
get away from him anyway I think that's
all his spoilery strikes too and I
really hope that you enjoy the breakdown
I had a blast together and I'm so glad
that HBO have done Justice to the game I
was worried they might mess it up and
though it's very it's very very early
days I think this first episode was
great really captures the feel of the
source material and as a fan I couldn't
have asked for more obviously I'd love
to hear your thoughts on whether you
agree or not but for me yeah this was a
great way to start the series dude that
was an amazing breakdown very
informative there were some science
things I learned like what we thought
was hair coming out of one one of the
runners ended up being actual notes it's
it's quarter steps yeah so I was like oh
that's cool I'm gonna look at it now as
a little bit of Starship Troopers like
the brain bug when it's coming out like
oh okay it's preparing to attack with it
that was gripping I learned a lot it was
edited really well there are things I
kind of forgot about yeah and also too
this this that one little Sarah detail
of why the soldier uh was given the
order to shoot them like I never even
thought about that I played the game a
million times a lot of this one this is
amazing this is one of your best videos
this is an amazing ass video all right
guys well subscribe to heavy spoilers
the king of breakdowns you can subscribe
to us as we uh continue our Last of Us
Journey John and Tara Erickson watching
last of us as well not having played the
game so getting two different kinds of
reactions here alrighty guys thank you
for being here follow Andrew on social
media talk to you all soon
[Music]